es miércoles 23 de septiembre y es
momento de hablar de economía con la
especialista daniel a blandón a quien
recibo con muchísimo gusto daniela eeuu
anunció nada sanciones al sector
turístico de cuba en qué consisten alan
muy buenas noches miren durante la
presidencia de barack obama las
restricciones contra cuba pues fueron ya
sabemos bastante minimizadas o
suavizadas pero desde que donald
trabajar asumió el cargo en 2017 pues se
han endurecido en 2019 se prohibieron
los viajes educativos en grupo hacia la
isla así como las embarcaciones
recreativas algunas de las nuevas
medidas las explica el jefe de la casa
blanca hoy anunció que el departamento
del tesoro prohibir a los viajeros
estadounidenses alojarse en propiedades
del gobierno cubano
también restringimos aún más la
importación de alcohol y tabaco cubano
de jackson estas acciones garantizarán
que los dólares estadounidenses no
financian al régimen cubano y vayan
directamente al pueblo otra de las
restricciones es que tampoco podrán
asistir a conferencias en cuba los
estadounidenses el presidente cubano
miguel díaz canel respondió que medidas
como éstas violan los derechos de los
cubanos y también de los estadounidenses
y agregó que su cruel y criminal
política será derrotada por un pueblo
que no renunciará a su soberanía las
naciones unidas la onu reveló un fuerte
descenso nuevamente los ingresos
salariales por culpa por supuesto
daniela de la pandemia si los ingresos
salariales globales se desplomaron en
3,5 billones de dólares en los primeros
nueve meses de 2012
esto representa una caída de casi el 11
por ciento con respecto al año anterior
según concluyó la organización
internacional del trabajo en el informe
hace énfasis en que después de la
pandemia se agudizará la brecha social
sobre todo en américa latina esta
agencia de la onu esto estimó que una
tercera parte del empleo global se ha
perdido durante la crisis sanitaria es
decir unos 500 millones de empleos y
cree que todavía se van a perder muchos
más escuchemos
presentamos tres escenarios posibles
para el cuarto trimestre y el escenario
de preferencia ahora proyecta que se
perderán 8,6 por ciento del tiempo del
trabajo global y esos cinco millones de
empleos equivalentes a tiempo completo
en bonos a chile de daniela y es que ya
comenzó la discusión para otro retiro
parcial de las pensiones claro que si
promete con encender de nuevo el debate
por este tema el parlamento chileno
empezó el análisis de un proyecto que
permitiría un segundo retiro del 10 por
ciento de los fondos de pensiones esto
se da apenas dos meses después de que
fuera aprobado un primer retiro del que
ya se beneficiaron más de 95 millones de
personas es decir casi nueve de cada
diez afiliados retiraron en promedio mil
565 dólares cada uno en total fueron
desembolsados más de 15 mil millones de
y esta segunda reforma buscaban dar
acceso al retiro de otro 10% pero
primero tiene que pasar en la cámara de
diputados y en el senado y después ser
aprobado en última instancia por el
presidente sebastián piñera quien se
opone a la medida y esto en europa están
buscando cómo deshacerse de los créditos
morosos ellos como parte de sus acciones
económicas si mire con la llegada de la
pandemia muchos ciudadanos se quedaron
sin dinero para pagar sus deudas eso es
una realidad por ejemplo tarjetas de
crédito préstamos para automóviles
hipotecas entre otros el banco central
europeo está preparando un mercado al
estilo amazon o ebay que funciona de la
siguiente manera las entidades tendrán
disponible una plataforma en internet
abierta para sacar a la venta de esas
carteras que saben que no van a
recuperar tan fácil y otras firmas
financieras pueden comprar las más
baratas bajo su propio riesgo eso sí y
esperar a que les den rentabilidad algún
día eso le sirve a todo el mundo hablar
por un lado de los bancos se deshacen de
esas deudas incobrables que sumadas
pueden ser alrededor de medio billón de
euros en toda la región
y de paso se mueve el dinero y se
dinamiza la economía hay liquidez no
bueno vámonos ahora con los indicadores
económicos del día
hoy soy de cerró con pérdidas bastante
pronunciadas entre el 2 y el 3 por
ciento la preocupación por el cob y 19
sigues animando a los inversionistas las
bolsas europeas en cambio subieron a
pesar de los malos datos de la actividad
empresarial en la zona euro y en américa
latina' cierres mixtos liderados por el
principal índice de la bolsa de sao
paulo finalizamos si te parece bien con
la cifra el día si el 13.1 por ciento al
que subió el desempleo en argentina
durante el segundo trimestre de 2020 la
tasa más alta en 15 años muchas gracias
por este recorrido económico daniela
blandón y muchas veces ustedes por su
compañía ya lo sabe vea más mucho más en
francés 24
[Música]